[Musica]
sicuramente non avete capito niente di
quello che avete visto quindi ho messo
questo cappello per confondervi ancora
un po di più le idee non avete capito
niente di quello che avete visto ma lo
capirete
guardando il video persone ragazzi e
ragazze esseri umani di questo millennio
fate un bel respiro
siete calmati adesso stiamo per entrare
nell'area più zen che voi abbiate mai
visto in tutta la vostra vita oggi
giochiamo a broc rialzi videogioco che
non c'è un impiccato a destra non fa
niente videogioco che entra nelle nostre
anime ci metterà tutti d'accordo per un
mondo migliore user maap questa non è il
menu questo sono io ok prese left click
to internet user name e uscite una vela
madonna può essere di keys to move ok
accetto no non ho capito visto dovrei
fare il suo gioco
ho scaricato questo gioco perché io
quando scarichi videogiochi non per
farli sul canale vedo gli screen non più
o meno come sono fatti questo gioco
negli screen c'era roba non capito c'era
tanta roba
e questo è quello che intendevo con roma
questo è il perché io ho portato questo
gioco credo sia uno dei titoli forse il
titolo più bello io possa mai portare
sul mio canale got life
ho trovato un corso per mettere mi piace
mi piace al cartello mi piace alla
colonna mi piace a delfino bello delfino
tentiamo di likes bivio like a good like
your life is hard tuning laicale perle
like
l'insegna laica fa tizia 01 chan è un
piacere averti con noi
la risposta è come installando 8 giorno
dove sono io
chi sei tu chi sei tu non preoccuparti
ho già preparato un account starter per
te credo che passare una giornata a fare
amicizia e dovresti incontrare uno dei
nostri topi user sir mi ha aperto la sua
grazie grazie mille vado a vado a farli
happy holidays anche a te ti mette
online ma stai giocando a solitario sa
cos'è va bene premi tab per vedere una
nuova avventura
porca vacca c'è una mappa intera ma è
bellissimo dopo paradiso tradisse
quindi io vado in giro e metto like ok
lo raccogliere il laico c'è la posta un
c'è altra gente
ciao persone di basso livello come me
oddio miglior cosa sto vedendo 6 singolo
cosa ma non lo so che tu sei un maschio
e una femmina innanzitutto can't find my
phone zio ce l'hai nell'orecchio ed è
veramente difficile che tu non riesca a
trovarlo e gigantesco c'è più grosso di
casa tua con il telefono non avevo in
mente questo gioco fosse così è ancora
meglio di quanto pensassi il tempo è
tutto ciò che hai già zia anno tu non ci
gioca solitario che strano solo nel 20
si sono risposti uguali tutte e due
vabbè che belli discorsi che si fanno in
questo hai vinto clicca qui per prendere
il premio e non l'ho mai fatto in vita
mia quando mi si riuscivano sti pop up
che salvatore aranzulla mi ha sempre
spiegato che nelle sbagliato cosa sto
vedendo via di qui andiamo avanti erca
vacca hai un virus clicca qui per
fissarlo si è un gioco dove metti mi
piace basta finissimo e lui maestro zen
signor maestro zen cosa il mao
togliti le scarpe quindi gracco di mi
sei venuto per imparare il cammino vuoi
spiegarmi che cosa renderà utili i miei
insegnamenti
mi piace la sua attitude ma poi c'è wifi
in mano devo tenere questa terra libera
da malware e spam
ma la mia katana e stata distrutta in
tre pezzi
portami pezzi e risorgerò la mia spada
per te e diventerà il mio successore
va bene e vado a prenderti pezzi della
katana atleti trovo in giro le gocce di
wi fi in quest'area c'è anche bluetooth
grazie maestro zen
grazie mille allora non posso entrare va
bene è un internet per chi fa quotidiano
uso di lsd sa perché c'è un cane che si
sta inglobando una palla ho messo mi
piace dei libri che sono scappati
ho trovato un pezzo della katana molto
ma non posso entrare quasi la strada del
dragone penso che debba avere la katana
prima o le ali a considerare il e cosi
quindi a veniamo di questa musica che
partirà è il gioco più bello del mondo
no che ci sono i pop up credo che laggiù
ci sia un altro pezzo della katana vado
a vedere posso immergermi nel ii qui se
vai così mi piace ai pesci ma sono
errori di windows i pesci laica i libri
ho trovato un segnalibro segnali a un
segnaposto a mili teletrasporto in un
posto che ho segnato carino allora li
mortacci lo ho trovato un like qua sotto
allora signori signori fatemi trovare le
cose giuste
la tavolozza di colori che figata
sono arrivati in punti dove gli altri
non sono arrivati quindi ottimo sono
anche dei like qua molti live che bello
sono più relight come gli influencer
questo presidente il mondo in cui vive
tipo la ferrai di pu pezzo la katana
pezzo dall'agata me ne rimane solo uno
che non ho idea di dove sia però vedo
della roba da giusti solo ci potesse
arrivare aspetto che vedo chissà se devo
passare realmente di costo pagando il
gioco questa è una cosa che non saprò
mai ma chi se ne frega andiamoci ciao
amici ma bo chronic parate che slide
soste anche dabato nel mentre po
poligonale
va beh io non so se realmente potevo
fare questa cosa mi sono stato forse il
meta gioco ma chi se ne frega a posso
fare amicizia con le persone che ci sono
all'interno di queste cose di queste
casette prendi questa camera va bene ho
trovato una videocamera più fatto faccio
più light faccio la faccio amicizia
ciao persone è una cosa molto ambigua
questa prova bep sorridi ti piace e ho
preso un po di like che non ci avete le
bocce vere cioè quello il film fall per
quello non prendete lei è esattamente
quello di cui avevo bisogno o questo sì
che fa like fratello che mi piace la
canzoncina che ce li sottofondo che non
ha veramente senso cosa sto vedendo poi
vedere delle foto del mio cane no grazie
però ve le faccio io le foto volentieri
penso che sia uno ligio persone normali
grazie di dio
molto bene
penso sia uno dei giochi forse il gioco
più attesa che io abbia mai fatto sul
mio canale c'è la prima volta che vedo
una roba qui eccoti non trovavo vi ha
fatto un sacco di foto anche a te a
posto anche sony che possono fotografare
06 fermo molto bene né o gesù cosa vedo
cos'è questa cosa cos'è spiegami sei
bellissimo complimenti al sono tornato
qua a me alla fine potevo fare il giro
stranamente posso passare di qua tipo
qui sotto qui sotto storia ci dovrebbe
essere la piscina dove ci dovrebbe
essere anche il l'admin che mi può
aumentare il livello dove rapisce salve
ciao persone posso per la foto l'entrata
molto bene il pezzo della katana un
let's go
abbiamo tutti pensi della katana ragazzi
possiamo andare dal tipo che figata
dovreste aprirmi in teoria mi aprite
potete aprire la porta perché devo
parlare con la di min
c'è una statua ma è che mi sta parlando
perdonami il mio nome è mister drone
makram sappi io sono a dobbiamo portare
un po di crema solare a voi
certo va bene e gli occhiali da sole e
del dentifricio sì grazie perché vi devo
fare la spesa io sono contento che devo
fare la spesa
vado assolutamente a prendervi quello
che mi avete chiesto crema solare e
dentifricio occhiali da sole va bene
dov'è il centro commerciale però ma c'è
una porta sott'acqua che non avevo visto
posso passare addirittura attraverso
vabbè sui like di ventun influencer vero
sto male ho trovato un miliardo li likes
va bene erano nascosti qua sotto
ragazzi su 323 l'ice in un sacco sono
quasi arrivato a 400 likes che il canone
ma mettete mi piace il video che ci
arriva ma no ma ragazzo non diventato un
esperto di trovare robe dietro le robe
sono bravissimo c'è una tizia ciao si
aspetta che ti faccio una foto possono
prendere un sacco di archi chi sei error
ho fatto informatica scuola però non mi
ricordo più niente quindi divertiti
finché dura va bene porca vacca di
gnocca in digitale avere non ho capito
se mia riacquistava riavviando qualcosa
mi ha avviato la registrazione non so
chi sta riavviando qualcosa tipo il
canale cosa è successo grazie zia
qualsiasi cosa tu abbia fatto per l'amor
di dio è perché se hai fatto cagate
torno e ti prende a testate il problema
è che non ho capito dove devo andare
cosa devo fare e perché piscina della
lussuria
ma no ma è chiusa eccola dove era è
chiuso o quasi tre o quattrocento live
ci sono quali vicinissimo quindi posso
dopo di che penso si apra con qualcosa
succede figura o comunque l'acqua mi dà
veramente fastidio è fatta tipo di
boh sembra quella roba che rimane che fa
schifo con la melma li orribile e non ho
ben capito il senso di mistero perché
l'acqua è fatta in digitale orribile
quindi se la cosa non è chiara
l'importante nella vita sono i like nas
capisci niente del gioco di ska p c è
niente è un gioco per drogati però i
like sono la cosa più importante questo
è un gioco significati insegna come si
vive al mondo al giorno d'oggi insomma
quindi in realtà non ha senso come gioco
però ha molto più senso di tante altre
cose
se vi dove piaciuto
sapete cosa fare
[Musica]